all right we're here with every clue
from Nvidia checking out to cool things
one guild wars 2 and 2 guild wars 2 in
3d using nvidia 3d technologies or
anything you can tell me about this
absolutely right here in the background
you see it's the only 103 inch 3d TV
it's basically the big as 3d TV and all
of us right now and we are exclusively
showing guild wars 2 this morning and
actually with killers too it's actually
3d we also have a 3d surround pod where
it has three modern 3d and completely
immersive so something like that we're
showing if with 3d technology all you
have to get is a 3d kit and you have to
have an 8800 GT or above and that's
basically all you need to really have 30
also you need a 120 Hertz monitor and of
course you could buy this TV which is
150 gram but hey that's fine that's fine
it's that it's totally worth it best
hundred fifty grand I would ever spend
that I don't have I fat can ask what
kind of games are supported is there a
list of games are definitely go on our
website there's oh there's pretty much
500 or so games that we've tested but
there's a lot more that we've never
tested that automatically works with our
technology minigames that the recent
most recent games Triple A titles like
mafia 2 is fully supported in 3d as well
as the reefs around other games are
showing the background as well we have
civilization 5 that's coming out that's
going to show off 3d as well we have so
many games that are just fully supported
I meeting you look back and think oh age
of empires are supported so it's tons of
games you spoke my language when you
said civilization 5 i'm not going to lie
but that's exactly where we're going
next ballpark cost will say average guy
out there he's watching this he wants to
get he wants to get a 3d game he wants
to see his games in 3d how much would
you have to drop not counting 150,000 so
you're thinking about a 30 TV you think
oh my god it's like three or four grand
I can't afford it you don't have to get
a 3d TV all you have to get is a 30
monitor which these days you can get for
about two hundred dollars it's a it's
only 120 Hertz monitor and some people
ready have it and then you have to get
the 3d kit which comes with a glasses in
the mirror which is right now 199 and
then if you already have an nvidia
geforce 8800 or above it's automatically
supported for our drivers so about four
or five hundred bucks you're
yeah 500 bucks you got some pc 3d 5
grand you have movies in which you need
to buy the 3d version of the movie and
then watch it on your 3d TV in this
upscale I mean 2d 2d video games are now
3d within video technologies for 3d
blu-ray as well for a few hundred bucks
I love it thanks a lot Eric good talking
with you alright let's go see
civilization 5 alright so I just got out
of a 20-minute presentation for
civilization 5 and I know a lot of you
out like myself we're concerned that
civilization 5 might have been dumbed
down some sort of civilization for a
light version of the game absolutely not
the case it may be more simple an
interface but it's much more involved in
politics faction in war they gave me
centered around a long term plan like
you make faction with one person you got
to keep that person happy you may have
to exchange money with them early on for
for a reward later on in the game that
reward may or may not come maybe they'll
get pissed at you halfway through the
game and they'll turn and you get
nothing now you're at war with no
resources whatsoever you really have to
think about what you do the same goes
for the battle mechanic you can't stack
more than one platoon on one hexagon at
a time so you really got to think about
where you move and it is possible
actually to enter a stalemate if you
don't have enough turns to go through
the hexagon get to the other side you
could have nowhere to go whatsoever in
the end civilization 5 comes out on the
21st in September this month I'm going
to get it civilization is the only game
that you can cook 12 hours and it seems
like three and a half minutes though
it's definitely on my get list alright
so in the world of 3d I think we found
its sole purpose the best purpose that
could have been created for and that's
actually killing zombies in 3d I just
played dead rising 2 in 3d learned a
couple things one killing zombies in 3d
is more fun than 2d and to the
sledgehammers still the coolest weapon
in the game and we're here at the
Nintendo booth the place where we can
get a glimpse of Donkey Kong Country
Returns what we can't get a glimpse of
is the 3ds there is no 3ds here why is
there no 3ds I'll take the dumbest thing
I've ever heard mine
life there is no 3d NVIDIA has 3d I can
go check that out nintendo no 3ds this
is [ __ ]